[Applause]
[Music]
but the use of water rescue
dogs obviously gives an extra gear.
Italian rescue dog school
was born in 1989 when
I am a Newfoundland named max and I
tried it starts in the east at the open rescue
in the water you save energy and
therefore a more operational rescuer
I say you need to understand that if
a sled starts you need  at least six dogs to
pull six people a dog is enough
about 20 30 per visit
per year on
average every year the
rescue list very many
there are those who talk about a scholastic saint and
decide if a skilled dog that has become
impossible is dogs  wrong and
clearly the difference of the master the
presence of the dog in front gives the thing
let's say my most beautiful reward is the
one that always the master dog at the
moment of the rescue  tage that unites
even more this relationship between a
dog and a human
[Music]